how are you doing today sir
I'm very well first of all I want to
stay start by saying how much I'm a fan
of your work and I think it's been a
while since we've spoken so it's really
cool to sit across from you thank you um
I want to jump backwards for a second
and say can you listen to Joy Division
on the radio or does it tweak you out
you know I went to see it recently and
there's a cinema in Berlin called the
can't Kino which is where Joy Division
played their only gig in Germany and it
was 40 years since they played there it
was a week after my 40th birthday and
they they were playing they played
control again so my wife and I thought
let's go and sneak in and watch it I
haven't seen it well we hadn't seen it
for however long it was like 14 years or
13 years whatever and I really had a
hard effect on me this this time I think
I was kind of depressed for a couple of
days not depressed but sad affected by
it the first time I saw it it was so
much also about us you know and it's
changed my life and everything but
watching it with a few years it was much
more I thought much more about Ian know
it's what a tragedy
I completely so you didn't tell me when
you were going
no I told to say I told the cinema but I
didn't tell anyone else but no one no
one recognized either of us we were
sitting in there there was full of Joy
Division fans I mean one guy put two and
two together that's that's amazing man I
I don't think people there were even why
would they think that you would be there
do you know what I mean like yeah I
suppose it seemed too random yeah
exactly
I'm jumping into why I get to talk to
you Congrats on the movie it is his
story their story is so amazing when you
were researching the role what were some
of the things that you took away that
really impressed you about Pierre and
their relationship there's a there's a
lot really I mean I was lucky that Mary
Curie wrote a book about
a small biopic which included all of his
you know a lot about his childhood and
he's really fascinating man you know
humanists and his parents were
incredibly modern and he had these you
know it wasn't about you know trying to
be about equality quarrel or whatever
they just lived it you know they it was
it was a given that they would have a
mutual respect for one another
you know the brilliance of the two of
them and the respect that they had for
each other and the hard the you know the
hard physical labor that it took to find
these you know these elements I had no
idea about that that you know they had
to smash up tons and tons of pitchblende
in a bath did he made them so ill you
know it's the whole the whole thing
fascinated me it was amazed that I did
how little I knew about it really I mean
I've heard of herb I didn't really
realize what a part he played in it as
well
yeah and also I I didn't realize how
much of a feminist he was in terms of
way ahead I mean he was the one who
insisted that they share the Nobel you
know and and just what they did yeah
it's just amazing yeah you know I mean
they they I think in order to bring in a
bit more dinant make it a bit more
dynamic we had to sort of make out that
there was some conflict in the hair
really which I don't think actually
existed in real in real life you know
because otherwise it's just
yeah probably nauseating to watch a
couple who are that perfect for one
another well I think also the fact is
that every movie is like no one thinks a
movie is a documentary unless you're
being foolish you know it's this is it's
designed to tell a story and get people
you know excited yeah at least for me
you know when you think back on the
making of the film you filmed in
Budapest I believe what's some of the
things you will always remember from the
shoot
oh it's tricky um I sobered up in
Budapest well that's probably not for
anyone see but yeah I mean that's the
most that's the most important thing
that happened for me obviously but it's
about it's a beautiful city it's a
daunting place as well you know my wife
grew up in Romania and some of these old
East Bloc places they still have a you
know I'm quite a heavy atmosphere I find
personally you're very right but the you
know the the the skill of the of the
workers there as well the costumes were
all you know made food to measure for me
and everything it was really you know
they're the the skill of the of the
workmanship was impressive and I enjoyed
it you know it's so it we lived a lot of
seasons while we were there it was
amazing you know it was it was very you
know four seasons in three months it
felt like as well very cold yeah what's
funny is I was in Budapest a few days
ago and experiencing I got to see what
it's like over there when they're making
movies and TV and it's pretty impressive
yeah I mean they shoot so much that
really it's it's awesome one of the
things is when you're making a movie or
TV show you you never know what the
schedule is gonna be you never know what
you're shooting on the first day what do
you typically hope that you're gonna be
doing on the first day or do you like
joking leaving a exit scar that sort of
thing as you know which often they do I
mean I've had you know they do sometimes
trying to warm you up with the less
taxing things I've had the opposite a
few times you know where I've done I did
that last year on Rebecca my big scene
with the most dialogue was the first one
and it's one of those days where you
they were gonna be ready for you in an
hour and then they come in with an hour
left to shoot and the day and say
do you think we can do this in an hour
yeah like yeah of course darling I'm a
professional right what's really funny
is I wanted to ask you about working
with Ben again you guys did great work
on free fire what what do you remember
about that shoe because that movie is
fantastic we had a good it was amazing I
wanted to work with Ben since I watched
kill list I thought he was really
exciting director so I was thrilled to
be an I mean to be part of that that
gang no it was amazing fun we had brie
Larson who's had just been
oscar-nominated or was just about to win
or something and the way he worked was
that we all we all were there at all
times you never knew where the camera
might might turn up so you've got like
army and breed lying in the dirt all day
you know just to catch a bit of their
elbow or something there was amazing
team teams where we shot a second movie
together with my wife as well called
Happy New Year call him burst ed which
played only on the BBC iPlayer but you
should check that out we we were meant
into another big film and they took them
whatever money money stuff and so he
rang me up and said I want to do a
remake of coal Coriolanus I'm gonna call
it Colin you anus and I was like haha
you know lulz it's like well and that's
it okay so we shot this we shot this
film in a week with amazing people Neil
Maskell from kill list
Hayley Squires who's in the what you
know the movie about the food banks in
England I remember and all this amazing
this amazing on cast the people we saw
this movie about a nightmare New Year's
Eve party in a week and it's on the BB
it's gonna come out on DVD at some point
so that's the third time I definitely
have not seen that it's really good I am
hundred percent sure gonna try and find
that a hundred percent I definitely want
to ask you though about working on
Rebecca and maybe what it was what for
people that are familiar with the
material
how has he put his unique spin on
well you know I haven't seen it but I
mean I think it's at first she sort of
thing are bands doing you know a remake
of a Hitchcock movie but actually if you
think of the source material this
psychological thriller is actually right
up his street you know if you think of
kill list or whatever you know he's
really good at amping up there the
horror you know and the fear and I think
he's gonna do something really really
great with it I mean I just love I love
working with him and I love that he
keeps hiring me for 100% but before I'm
about to run out of time with you but I
have to ask you I'm a big fan of bank
heists like Ocean's eleven and I'm a fan
of the criminal underworld yeah we type
movies so I noticed way down is this is
going to be great I think we have so
much fun it's a it's a caper you know
like in the old sense of a bit like do
you not like the Italian job but one of
these sort of you know harebrained idea
to get inside the National Bank of Spain
using the the World Cup of whatever 2009
whenever their Spain won the World Cup
in South in South Africa where all the
fans are going to be on the streets of
Madrid watching the the final and we're
gonna try and rob the bank during that
with amazing internet liam liam
Cunningham a strippers frisbee Freddie
Highmore and luis das are great Spanish
actor and we had a hoot you know I was I
learned scuba diving and abseiling
through windows and [ __ ] it was my dream
dream job I mean I love I know I'm more
well-known for their crying and smoking
but I really it's I want to be an action
hero I really can't wait to see it
congratulations on this you did
fantastic work thank you so much for
your time my pleasure